no matter where it is you are on your
property journey this event is for you
you might be at a brand-new beginner
who's just getting started in property
or you might be a seasoned professional
the property investors crash course has
it all Samuel Leeds is a property
investor an entrepreneur he got into
property aged 17 and by the age of 21 he
was financially free he's now a
multi-millionaire and he teaches
property investment all over the UK he's
well known as the UK's most inspiring
property investor and chances are if you
watching this video who's already
inspired you there's gonna be training
covering lease option agreements HMOs
rent to rent service accommodation it
really is a fantastic grounding for any
property investor unlike normal training
courses where the training is done at
you Samuel interacts with everybody he
makes live calls and it gets you to do
it too so you're actually doing the do
in the room there are gonna be people
who attend the crash course who buy
deals that they have found while they
were there there are gonna be people who
go on to become financially free as a
direct result of what they learnt at
this event and the best part is at the
moment is completely free to attend so
what are you waiting for
get booked on this is the property
investors crash course
[Applause]
[Music]